most people probably don't even know the
first person in the space in America and
obviously everybody knows that in uh
that it's it's like um
it's kind of interesting how the space
race
and even World War II
even like the history books you ask most
Americans
they think that America won World War II
like without America like they the the
real heroes of World War II is America
yes uh British people they say and and
everybody has a pretty good
justification like without Britain
without Churchill
their Hitler would have taken over the
world and I think probably the strongest
case is the Soviet Union case that
they're the ones that won the war the
reason it's the strongest cases were
most of the fighting happened right most
of the death happen most of like most of
the destruction but everyone has their
perspective and certainly on the space
race
you know the great accomplishment is the
first man on the Moon
yeah I was gonna say and then you're a
Gagarin from the Russian perspective
first man in space and that I think
still persists in some of that in
healthy forms is probably constructive
to a little bit of competition this
pushes all the all the great scientists
on each side but anyway what do you
think about
this uh Ura Gagarin mission of the first
human in space
and the vastoc mission in 1961 just in
general when you when you look back at
that time leading to the the the the the
first man on the Moon
yeah April 12 1961. Yuri's night baby
that's uh yeah it's it's insane what's
insane to me is is the first
person in space didn't just go to space
he went into orbit you know you're going
flew around the Earth in orbit and
re-entered that's a Monumental task
compared to suborbital so the United
States did two suborbital flights in
that same year I believe in that same
year at least I'm pretty sure in 1961
they flew for the first time orbitaly in
1962's they weren't terribly far behind
to get a human into orbit like in the
grand scheme of things you know 10
months difference but at the same time
like the fact that Soviet Union just
went straight to Flying someone into
orbit is Monumental and I'm sure they
did not do excessive
uh rigorous testing here because there
is a space race and you have the first
is important just imagine being Yuri
what do you say when they're like
launching them like let's go or
something like uh I mean you're taking
uh dude we're talking about you being on
Starship like you're taking a pretty big
risk being launched out into orbit oh
hopefully a lot less risk than what Yuri
went through so Yuri's Yuri the crazy
thing remember those match sticks we
talked about yeah you know there's
there's 20 Main combustion Chambers on
soyuz and there's four and 12 more
Vernier engines that all need to be lit
so you're riding you're sitting on top
of this this booster and they light all
of those 32 combustion Chambers on the
ground and then it has this insane
separation process between what the
Soviet Union would call the first stage
in the second stages but we would call
it like the core stage and the boosters
um they all for these boosters have to
peel away perfectly from the core stage
simultaneously you know if one of them
sticks on Mission failed if one of them
doesn't inject properly and drags into
the other tank you know you're it's it's
a goner so the the staging process of of
the soyuz is is insane to me that that
ended up working out
I I was just the the technology in
stories and I mean more or less that
same rocket is what's still flying
humans
that are cosmonauts from Universe Cosmos
and going to the International Space
Station are flying on a variant of that
soyuz rocket still today it's still
like that big of a Workhorse what do you
think about Russ Cosmos as it stands
today uh it's history and its future
in uh comparison to NASA and other
National efforts and in comparison to
commercial space like yeah
I mean utmost respect for the engineers
involved and you know everything that's
happened I think uh nergomosh is like
still some of the one of the greatest
engine manufacturers when they have the
funding to do so but man it seems like
they're they're
falling from Grace as far as uh space
prowess you know the Roche Cosmos went
from
having I think they got very comfortable
at the top of you know from 2011 until
2000 until 2022 or until 2020 they were
the only ride to the International Space
Station
since then like and it started I feel
like in 2018 honestly I think that's
kind of one things that's the first time
I specifically remember a pretty nasty
like thing happened in 2018 I think it
was a soyuz mission to the International
Space Station had one of the boosters
not detached and had to have an abort
but you know that that happened then all
of a sudden next thing you know there's
a progress being docked to the ISS a
couple years ago that spun the ISS
cartwheel the ISS out of control
followed a few months later the piers
module docks of the International Space
Station spirals the International Space
Station out of control again with like a
Thruster getting fixed on there's a hole
in in as Russian segment uh there's well
I think the most recent one right now
there's a soyuz doc to the ISS that has
a puncture in it and it's leaking
coolant and will not be returning humans
on it so they're actually having to fly
up and uncrewed soyuz and that one
likely wasn't a manufacturing error it
probably was like a micro meteorite
puncture rendering spacecraft unusable
we don't know for sure yet
but it's just really been like this fall
from grace where and they have they have
all the potential potential they have
some of the best engines some of the the
best rockets and especially like right
before the collapse of the Soviet Union
the the bronze uh shuttle and the
inergia rocket were incredible had they
been able to evolve that into Bronto and
the reusable and ergia they had a fully
reusable energy on the drawing board and
like I honestly fully think they could
have done it